all right a new book is out it's called
battle for the soul barack obama quoted
as saying donald trump is a madman a
racist a sexist pig an effing lunatic
and a corrupt mother effort during his
candidacy and presidency
so tonight we have a special message for
barack first off
i never thought that we'd ever have a
president that started his entire
political career in the home of not one
but
two unrepentant domestic terrorists
whose group the weather underground
bombed the nypd police headquarters the
state department the u.s capitol and
more
and don't forget by the way one of his
domestic terrorist pals bill ayers he
was quoted in the new york times
of all days 9 11 2001 that morning
saying
he wished they did more i don't regret
setting bombs obama they were your
friends
that's sick i never thought we'd have a
president that sat in the pews of a
radical pastor for 20 plus years
who the sunday after 9 11 said no no no
not god bless america gd america and
america's chickens coming home
to roost take a look no no no
not god bless america god damn america
that's in the bible
now we are indignant because the stuff
we have done overseas
is now brought right back into our own
front
yards america's chickens
are coming home to roost
and i never thought barack that we'd
have a president that brought
black liberation uh theology and bought
into that
i never thought we'd elect a president
that for that hid for his entire
presidency his relationship
with that radical racist anti-semite
from the nation of islam louis farrakhan
they hid that picture from america for
nine years
what a disgrace or president that
recounted
reverend wright's sermon white folks
greed runs a world in need
here's barack saying it it is this world
a world where cruise ships throw away
more food in a day than most residents
of port-au-prince see in a year
where white folks greed runs a world in
need apartheid in one hemisphere
apathy in another hemisphere and i never
thought we'd elect the
disciple of radical saul olinsky or
president
bragging about doing drugs with his chum
gang
and said that even tried drugs
enthusiastically
great message for kids
i spent the last two years of high
school in the days locking away the
questions that life seemed insistent on
posing i kept playing basketball
attended classes sparingly
drank beer heavily and tried drugs
enthusiastically
i discovered that it didn't make any
difference whether you smoked reefer in
the white classmate sparkling new van
or in the dorm room with some brother
you'd met down at the gym
or on the beach with a couple of
hawaiian kids who had dropped out of
school and now spent most of their time
looking for an excuse to brawl
and you lied millions of americans lost
their doctors their plans and we're
paying about
200 more your presidency was a failure
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else